these are all the same global which one
do you recognize why how did the venus
de milo an armless ancient statue go
from being lost on a tiny Greek island
to an international icon it's part of a
story that spans centuries in a possible
cover-up that starts with a missing
piece right here this sculpture is so
popular that you can easily find a 3d
scan of it that's really good quality
and then get it printed in the sculpture
itself provides a clue to her popularity
because it contains her history really I
hope I don't screw this up
story is hidden right here
in the scene in 1820 a Greek farmer
discovered pieces of a woman carved from
marble on his Lane he sold wood he
founded the French for about a thousand
francs today that'd be around eleven
thousand us enough for a decent used car
they took this home a Venus split in two
along with some other scattered marble
fragments Venus has a bunch of
imperfections the arms were not still
attached other flaws marred the body she
was missing her earlobes probably taken
by looters a foot was gone there in a
likely base called a plinth had broken
off that would have been right about
here each half was meant to be joined in
the center with iron Tenon's
imagine two metal rods joining the two
halves the rest of the parts likely fell
off due to age when she was a symbol her
scale was really impressive at 6 feet 7
inches high and with a 12 and a half
inch foot its large Shack esque foot
[Music]
but Venus's looks weren't the most
important factor in her success for that
you've got to look to the circumstances
in which she was dug up in the French
art world it was in turmoil this drawing
of the Sphinx was made by Napoleon
Bonaparte's personal art looter vivo de
No
he drew it during his tour of Napoleon's
Egypt when he was searching for art to
plunder classical art was considered the
most desirable he tied to the greatness
of Rome and Greece while Napoleon spent
20 years trying to take over the world
Danone took art from everywhere Napoleon
succeeded he directed the louvre museum
under Napoleon's rule and filled it with
the art that he stole when Napoleon lost
his throne that massive cache of
classical art had to be returned to its
owners suddenly the Louvre and France
had a huge problem for example the
Vatican got back lacunae and his sons
and the Apollo Belvedere and the
Italians were reunited with their own
looted Venus Venus de Medici the Louvre
wasn't empty but it was desperate then
five years later Venus turned out on an
island in Greece the French were willing
to do just about anything to regain the
classical art that they lost when
Napoleon got kicked out even massaged
the truth remember that plinth that got
broken off of the statue right here we
know what the plinth looked like thanks
to early drawings by the sculptors name
on it and some other clues it
definitively dated the Venus to a
hundred thirty to a hundred BC what is
called the Hellenistic era that was a
problem it was 200 years after the
Classical period the one that the
critics loved so the French tried to
hide it the plinth got lost before Venus
went on display in the Louvre in 1821
with the plinth taking care of the
museum's director declared Venus was
definitely classical not Hellenistic and
the Louvre supported critics who called
Venus a work of classical Greek genius
they gave her a primes
but in the gallery and insisted it was
certainly the well-known goddess Venus
even though she didn't have a label
competing interpretations of what
Venus's missing arms were doing surfaced
and the Louvre supported the ones they
thought made Venus look most important
all of this worked
Venus held a prime spot in the galleries
and became iconic the Louvre insisted
that she was classical all the way until
1951 when they finally reversed course
her unique fame was the result of the
Louvre branding campaign to regain
national pride it's that history that
makes her the Venus we recognize maybe
the history is the reason she's still
worth seeing today okay so one little
public service announcement if you want
to get your own venus de milo 3d printed
I put a link to a really nice model in
the description below and I actually got
mine done at the local library so maybe
you can too and don't make the same
mistake I didn't get yours in hot pink
or lime-green
[Music]